je m'appelle tal levvine j'aurais
bientôt 17 ans et j'habite Jérusalem
hier soir il y a eu un attentat dans un
café près de chez moi je ne comprends
pas que la vie tienne à ça avoir envie
ou pas d'aller au café d'en
bas à chaque attentat on entend ralbol
des Palestiniens mais les Palestiniens
c'est
qui toi qui trouveras cette bouteille
réponds-moi à cette adresse dis-moi où
tu l'as trouvé qui tu es parle-moi de
toi s'il te
[Musique]
plaît fait des nouvell de ta
boutille
[Musique]
est gu avec tu comprends ça
Guer tu sais m pas avec
qui depu une semain je m'quiète dis-moi
juste si tu vas
bien c'est trop dur à gaz en ce moment
je ne peux pas te raconter mais si tu
veux savoir des choses sur moi je
m'appelle et maintenant j'ai une ami à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Jérusalem